we begin with a stark new warning about
the future severity of this coronavirus
crisis in a Washington Post interview
CDC director dr. Robert Redfield says
this we could see a second wave of the
virus next winter and he says it could
be even more difficult than what is
happening right now
yikes because it would hit at the same
time as a flu season that's just one of
many unknowns facing governor's as they
decide when and how to reopen their
states
mark Strassmann is in hard-hit Atlanta
where the mayor says she wasn't even
consulted by Georgia's governor before
he decided to partially reopen in a
couple of days from now mark how our
business is handling all this we're
about to find out Anthony and a good
morning Georgia ranks in the top 15 of
most infected states nonetheless this
state is getting ready for what you
might call a soft open certain
businesses can unlock their doors for
customers if they follow social
distancing and sanitation guidelines as
some of the states around the country
began to relaxed social distancing
restrictions the reality of what normal
will look like is starting to sink in
it's scary from all aspects lindsay nash
owns a georgia hair salon and is getting
back to work governor brian kemp
announced his plan to begin reopening
the state this Friday shutting down for
much longer wouldn't be an option
because we don't know how long the
pandemic will go on but some residents
and political leaders disagree with
governor Kemp including the mayor of
Albany Georgia the city has endured one
of the highest per capita infection
rates in the country dr. deborah birx
the White House coronavirus response
coordinator says it's important for
governors and mayor's to follow the
reopening guidelines it will have to be
on a community by community opening I
believe people in Atlanta would
understand that if their cases are not
going
down that they need to continue to do
everything that we said social
distancing perks is worried about
asymptomatic spread a concern bolstered
by new antibody research it suggests
many more Americans may have been
infected by kovat than first thought
we're not opening up all businesses as
usual by any means many businesses in
South Carolina have already been given
the greenlight in a state where only
about 42,000 people have been tested for
the virus some North Carolina public
beaches are now open some retail - like
department stores in Texas Dallas County
officials voted to extend their stay at
home order through the middle of next
month
Texans really want to get back to work
it's kind of part of the Texas DNA but
governor Greg Abbott says his
forthcoming plan for reopening will
overrule any local policy to me I'm a
movie tuckson Susan Morrison lives in
Dallas she lost her 39 year old
stepbrother and her 83 year old father
took Ovid 19 on consecutive days to not
be able to see your family member died
our to be there hold their hands and to
just hear oh he's gone the White House
has set certain standards for states to
reopen and one of them is a two-week
downward trend of new kovat cases Gail
by that standard Georgia fails all right
mark thank you very much